The OnePlus 7 Pro is a really nice device,
and with a starting price that sounded surprisingly
low after all of its features and specs were
revealed.
Its got a beautiful super smooth display,
dual stereo speakers, and top of the line
performance specs, but after spending a week
with it, I have to say I wouldn’t buy it.
Now don’t get me wrong, it's not a bad phone
by any means, in fact, its industry-leading
in multiple areas, but it's not without its
flaws, and in many areas its just good, not
great.
I’ll let you know exactly what those are
including which phone I’d buy instead, but
first, let's talk about what they got right.
The exterior design not only looks nice, but
feels very premium.
Aluminum sandwiched by curved gorilla glass,
Subtle logo and text on the back, perfectly
located buttons, the same triple mute switch
that I love, and hefty weight that adds to
the premium feel.
We don’t have waterproofing rating but various
videos and breakdowns have shown it's up to
the task so I wouldn’t worry.
The center of attention is the massive curved
OLED display coming in at 6.7 inches.
It's bright, has great color accuracy, and
is super sharp.
As you can see there isn’t any kinda notch
or cutout and at the same time we have very
slim bezels.
Not only that, but the 90hz refresh rate paired
with great software makes using it the most
smooth experience I’ve ever had on a smartphone.
To make this fullscreen experience possible
OnePlus designed a motorized front facing
camera and I think this is probably the best
solution for the notch issue.
They showed it holding over 50lbs of weight
which is crazy, and say it's rated for over
300,000 actuations, so I don’t think durability
should be an issue but only time will tell.
Inside of that popup is a really good 16MP
F2 selfie camera, and on the back we have
3 more in a layout that's been very popular
recently, a standard, a telephoto, and an
ultrawide.
OnePlus chose to go with a 48MP main camera
instead of Apples and Samsungs 12MP, and on
the telephoto an 8MP 3x zoom, which was found
to actually be a 13MP 2.2 that they crop into
which makes sense since the zoomed images
don't look much better than 2x systems cropped
in digitally.
The photo and video capabilities are much
better than any previous device and very good
overall, but is it enough to take on the flagships?
No, not really.
Many images look fantastic but it's inconsistent.
Some shots turn out perfect while many others
have highlights pulled down too much, and
other having too much contrast or denoising.
The same inconsistency shows up in the video
as well, and some things are just missing
like video recording with a wide angle.
The sensors are great but the software still
needs tweaking which means OnePlus can improve
it, but at this time the 7 Pro can’t compare
with the S10+ or XS Max.
If you want to see a detailed comparison I’ll
link it after the video.
Although the camera needs work, I have to
say it again, OnePlus has the best Android
Software.
The icons, shortcuts, keyboard, and quick
animations are better than even stock android
and we also finally have an out of the box
screen recorder on an Android.
This wouldn’t be possible without great
hardware and in typical OnePlus fashion we
have a flagship Snapdragon 855 processor with
a ton of ram, up to 12GB in fact and OnePlus
can actually make use of that with their RAM
Boost feature that preloads software.
Add in brand new UFS 3 storage which in the
real world doubles read and write speed, and
you have a crazy fast phone that loads apps
noticeably faster than the competition.
The optical fingerprint sensor, in my opinion,
is now just as good as a physical one, and
definitely better than Samsungs ultrasonic.
So that's a bunch of great features of the
OnePlus 7 Pro, and when you pair that with
a $700 price tag for the model most will likely
choose, the 8GB RAM 256GB storage I’m using,
the value proposition is incredible, so why
wouldn’t I buy one?
The biggest culprit is the S10+ and the fact
that just two months later its been deeply
discounted on multiple websites bringing it
down from the $1000 I paid, to as low as $700
for an international model or just a bit more
for a Snapdragon version.
That is just crazy, I’ll leave some link
in the video description for some of the deals
I’ve found.
If the OnePlus 7 Pro was released half a year
ago it would have destroyed the market, or
if the S10+ stayed at $300 more the 7 Pro
would be a no brainer, but with Samsungs flagship
being available so close in price the OnePlus
is hard to recommend for most.
When we compare them side by side the OnePlus
falls behind in too many areas.
The battery charger is super fast but you
have to use both their proprietary charger
and cable, and the 4000MAh battery is large
but the 90hz display drains the battery so
much that I couldn’t ever get a full day
of use like I can with the S10+ which still
has 10-15% remaining.
To make matters worse we still don’t have
wireless charging so you can’t leave it
on a stand to top off throughout the day.
I understood it at $530, but I think at this
price point, paired with the “Pro” name
and high battery drain, OnePlus needed to
include it.
The display is nice, but it also can’t compete.
Samsungs is quite a bit brighter and HDR videos
look much better on the S10, and the same
thing goes for speakers, the S10+ blows the
OnePlus 7 Pro’s average stereo pair way
in sound quality and volume.
It's nice not having a cutout but the curved
portion of the screen starts bending much
earlier so reflections are a bigger issue.
If you like listening to music and watching
videos on your phone the S10 is definitely
ahead.
The S10’s camera quality is much more consistent
and overall better in both photos and video,
especially for the ultrawide lens where the
photos are far ahead because of processing,
are wider, and allow for video recording with
a cool super steady feature.
You do get 128GB of slower but still fast
storage as the base but the SD card slot will
accept up to another 512, and for those that
use wired headphone we still have a headphone
jack.
And I’m leaving my biggest to complaint
for last, and that the size and weight.
I never thought I’d say it but this smartphone
screen is just too big.
I love the large screens but 6.7” paired
with 206 grams means that in some of my pants
it actually sticks out of the pocket.
My hands were noticeably more tired when watching
youtube for a while and playing games compared
to the S10+ which is smaller, thinner, and
about 20% lighter while still having a large
6.4” display.
In the real world, this phone will be too
large for most people, and that's before adding
a case.
The OnePlus 7 Pro is a really nice phone that
leads in multiple areas but to achieve that
they had to raise the cost.
At the same time, competition has really upped
its game and is still ahead like they were
in previous years, but now the price tags
are closer together.
If your priority is a super smooth experience
both with software and display, and fast specs
for a great gaming experience it could still
make sense, but for most people, if you can
spend just a bit more, I think the S10+ is
a better choice.